je vais donc partir pour arriver à la
havane
ensuite je vais prendre le parti de
remonter un ici sur la côte d'une vielle
dans son bureau alain crampons 70 ans
peaufine les derniers détails pour sa
nouvelle aventure cette arcisien qui a
déjà parcouru à vélo la france le
portugal l'espagne et le canada en dix
ans va prendre l'avion le 8 décembre
prochain
destination cuba cet aventurier dans
l'âme à parcourir en deux mois plus de
2000 kilomètres sur l'île en dormant
chaque soir dans une ville différente
c'est un peu l'aventuré parce que j'ai
jany cinéraire je sais que le matin
quand je me lève je vais le soir me
retrouver à peu près 70 ou 80 km plus
loin
mais c'est tout c'est la seule chose qui
m'importe c'est que demain est ailleurs
et puis voilà je me promène le nez au
vent
pendant son périple un crampon emmènera
dans ses bagages un sac de survie de 15
kg avec des vêtements des médicaments et
des outils qui l'installera sur une
remorque
l'ensemble sera tracté à coups de
pédales sur un vélo tout terrain préparé
spécialement pour l'occasion
alors en fait c'est un vtt un très beau
vtt que j'ai eue pour mes 60 ans bien et
que j'ai équipé en grand tourisme
donc j'ai mis des cornes ici pour être
pouvoir pédaler super à l'aise comme sur
une harley davidson
j'ai mis un rétroviseur
parce que ça c'est absolument
indispensable et puis unis si c'est pour
le quotidien et éventuellement je peux
mettre un fruit ou une boîte de sardines
selon ce que je trouve en plus d'un vélo
étudié pour paraître toutes les épreuves
cet ancien rugbyman a également pensé à
travailler sa condition physique
sa recette un entraînement dans les
forêts des yvelines deux à trois fois
par semaine pour garder ses jambes de 20
ans mais pour ce grand père cet exploit
n'a rien de sensationnel
de toute façon c'est de la randonnée
c'est la promenade donc il n'y a pas
d'urgence
si on a un peu mal aux fesses au début
parce que ça peut arriver
ben on fait moins de kilomètres la
moyenne ces 15 km heure de moyenne c'est
que dalle donc 15 km heure pour regarder
la nature
c'est fabuleux et en plus on avance
parce que trois heures le matin et puis
de trois heures l'après-midi ben on a
fait 60 70 km c'est c'est simple c'est
simple comme un coup de
retour prévu en france le 8 février
prochain avec des souvenirs plein la
tête et peut être quelques courbatures
dans les gens quant aux bars hasta luego
[Musique]